ils sont exploités dans des conditions
respirer salut tout le monde j'espère
que vous allez bien dans cette vidéo on
va parler de mon dernier documentaire
qui est sorti en intégralité sur la
plate forme brute x et qui s'appelle qui
vous je suis parti en république
démocratique du congo plus précisément à
l'est du pays dans la région du kivu qui
est une zone de conflit depuis plus de
25 ans je vous montre tout de suite le
teaser du documentaire pour vous ayez
une idée de ce que j'ai pu filmer sur
place ah oui beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de jeunes des adolescents et
des kalachnikovs c'est impressionnant ce
nom vous dit c'est pire simple et unique
et la valeur de les relis mon existence
[Musique]
ces jeunes qu'on portait une arme la
tire donc à dire tant qu'athée tu as
déjà tué des gens comme vous avez pu
voir c'était un tournage extrêmement
intense et difficile
et pour cette vidéo je voulais qu'on
revienne sur la partie qui concerne les
mines de coltan le coltan c'est un
minerai qui est utilisé dans la
fabrication de certains de nos objets
électroniques comme les téléphones
portables ou les ordinateurs et la
république démocratique du congo
posséderait plus de 60 % des réserves
mondiales de ce minerai c'est pour ça
que j'ai voulu me rendre sur place pour
voir les conditions de travail des
personnes qui s'occupent de l'extraction
du minerai sur place j'ai pu pénétrer
dans deux mines et chaque descente dans
les tunnels
durée environ 20 à 25 minutes dans le
montage du documentaire évidemment on
n'a pas tout garder parce que ça aurait
été trop longue c'est pour ça que dans
cette vidéo je voulais vous mettre en
exclusivité la première descente que
j'ai fait est la plus longue
évidemment je vais pas vous mettre les
25 minutes de rushes que j'ai avec ma
groupe pro parce que c'est extrêmement
long mais je voulais le laissait
suffisamment longtemps que vous puissiez
comprendre à quel point c'est
extrêmement difficile et dangereux de
travailler dans cet endroit vous
prévient ceux qui ont des soucis de
claustrophobie vous déconseille de
regarder cette vidéo parce que ça peut
très vite devenir étouffante bref j'en
dis pas plus je vous laisse regarder
[Musique]
panier de yelena
oui mais je nous largue pour dessein
était quasiment le plafond et mes
épaules pas sa peine je suis armé de 88
autant dire you c'est un peu compliqué
vous
papa il ya des gens en bas une union des
jeux dé certains voient pas pourquoi pas
donc là il appelle et il est tellement
bas qu'on n'a pas tellement moderne quoi
vous achats il appelle et l'autre
l'entend pas tellement il est un athlète
il est profondément dialogue rachat
devant nouzon gardien koval heures sa
descente en vous dire que si elle monte
problème les vues des distances à
parcourir ce ses profonds c'est le butin
je passe pas
je pense pas
mallet
en tant que telle celle au problème
impossible de rohff retourner mais sa
page
c'est impossible de rentrer à temps mais
de sortir
ainsi les moindres époux jean c
je terminais quoi doit être à 30
trente voire quarante mètres leyti aura
tout d'abord c'est la seconde couche est
assez la seconde couche et on y va tous
vous continuer de creuser une côte est
où là donc là vous avez atteint la
deuxième couche de roche et polato de la
tv
en fait vous devez continuer de creuser
pour atteindre les sables minéralisés
ok là bas c'est papa continue de
descendre
on va voir j'ai pas beaucoup d'oxygène
moi j'imagine mon frère quand tu
passes 12 heures par jour dans la mine
[Musique]
tellement étroit ils ont pied des
fortifications
contrairement à la première il ya des
tuyaux en métal permet de maintenir la
terre un petit coup
en été les ans la bido la veulent aller
vers cette lola était d'accord gelé pour
l'atteindre avant son hockey un footing
[Musique]
jabouille année
we are the world
sa peine consulter si ça c'est faux
[Musique]
non pas par des retombées du sable
rentres tu rentres entre glissant là non
c'est non pas comme ça oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà si les ennemis qui récolte
le sables minéralisés
oui franchement c'est incroyable trois
doit faire la 32ème il le met dans des
petits sacs et ensuite ils remontent ces
cinq jusqu'à la surface
j'ai ramené ma lumière mais sinon ils
sont juste avec des lampes torches
frontale
donc il y voit pas grand chose ils sont
dans l'obscurité quasiment toute la
journée
il est rentré à quelle heure dans la
mode et l'art et oui il passe huit
heures dans la mine dans ces conditions
oui
c'est hallucinant enfin c'est dingue si
jamais vu ça ils sont pas de nourriture
vous en mangez des pommes d'été et ils
ont de l'eau pour boire ou pas
escamotable 0 il n'a pas un pays dont
ils ont jadot pour boire juste pour vous
donner une idée là il passe donc huit
heures par jour dans ces tunnels à 40
mètres de profondeur ils n'ont pas d'eau
et aujourd'hui ils avaient juste amener
quelques patates pour manger est-ce
qu'ils ont peur quand ils travaillent
ici qui n'ont pas peur
et là il continue de creuser de ce côté
là alors au bout il ya de l'eau alors
vraiment flippant vous rendez compte à
quel point c'est dangereux ou pas c'est
comment pouvoir faire pour évacuer
c'était pour mieux y arriver ici que
nous effectuions c'était est-ce qu'on
peut remonter un sacs de sables
minéralisés
oui oui on pourra alors on va monter ok
je venais lycée travaille pour nous
encourager
c'était mal à respirer
faut pas être pressé un passionnant ben
si vous commencez à perdre son souffle
[Musique]
sacha pitoeff
bah
[Musique]
je suis papa mais ça va je t'attends
steam je t'aime
avec le sac
il doit transporter cinq ans ils sont
fiables
bientôt une et réalisés au caire
[Musique]
à
tu as même à commande assistée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voulais sortir
son choix
à chaque fois franchement faut loger
[Musique]
c'est grave
moi en bas au fond j'avais peur
yakult chili nascar au décolleté rien
compris vous avez beaucoup de courage
même si évidemment quand je suis sorti
de la mine j'étais hyper ému parce que
déjà la descente est extrêmement
difficile comme ça ait pu voir et parce
que ma voir les trois gamins au fond de
la mine qui bosse et il avait l'air
hyper jeune je pense qu'ils avaient la
vingtaine samassa m'a forcément beaucoup
touché et quand je suis sorti j'ai
longtemps discuté avec eux sur place
aussi pour leur dire que je trouvais
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de courage même
si ça change rien à leur quotidien et
j'allais montrer ces images dans mon
pays sur un média qui a quand même
beaucoup d'audience pour que les gens
sachent la réalité de leur quotidien et
pour ce documentaire je suis aussi allé
voir le docteur denis mukwege et qui
avait reçu le prix nobel de la paix en
2018 pour son aide humanitaire auprès
des victimes de violences sexuelles et
de viols en république démocratique du
congo il parle aussi très souvent des
conditions de travail dans les mines de
son pays et pour lui la responsabilité
se situe vraiment au niveau des
multinationales qui ne font pas
suffisamment attention à la traçabilité
de ces minerais et par répercussion aux
conditions de travail des gens qui
s'occupent d'extraire ces minerais
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
intéressé
le documentaire est disponible dans son
intégralité sur la plate forme brute 6
j'ai hâte de vous montrer la suite de ce
que je prépare parce qu'il ya du très
très lourd a très vite